[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلوها بابرز
العنوي
اعدامات جديده
بحضور محامين
غنشن
واوروبا والحلف يؤكد ثقته بانضمام السويد
تحتوي الاف البنادق الهجوميه البحريه
الامريكيه تضبط سفينه ايرانيه تهرب سلاحا
للحوثيين
لا
يقلق وبكين تفرض اجراءات عقابيه على طوكيو
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من الملف الايراني
بحق شخص على خلفيه ضلوعه في الاحتجاجات
التي تشهدها البلاد هذا وافاد موقع ميزان
اون لاين اتابع لسلطه القضائيه عن صدور
حكم باعدام جواد روحي مما يرفع الحكم
الجديد اجمالي عدد احكام العقوبه القصوى
صادره في قضايا متصله بالاحتجاجات الى
18 حكما تم تنفيذ اربعه منها بينما صادقت
المحكمه العليا على حكمين اخرين
واحتجاجا على الاعدامات اصدر المجلس
التنسيقي لنقبات المعلمين الايرانيين
بيانا طلب فيه بوقف احكام الاعدام بحق
جميع المتهمين واستئناف المحاكمه العادله
لهم بحضور المحاميهم مؤكدا ان سياسه الخوف
والضغط ستحرق في النهايه اسس القهر والظلم
البيان قال ان القصه الاكثر الى امن لهذه
الاعدامات هي ان النظام الذي يدعي انه حكم
المظلومين والفقراء ويحكم باسمهم باسمهم
يقتل فقراء في المجتمع وفي نفس الوقت
امبابهم مضيفا ان الشعارات المخادعه في
اربعه عقود ان الدين والاخلاق وجميع
الاعراف لم تكن سوى غطاء لنهب راس المال
المادي والروحي الايرانيين
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا منه
ناشطه سياسيه ايرانيه والمتحدثه باسم حمله
انقذوا شارماد
سابدا بدايه اهلا وسهلا بك سابدا من يعني
كيف من داخل السجن اليوم وضع شرمها داخل
السجن كيف هو كيف تتم المحاكمه يعني كل
هذه التفاصيل لو سمحت وهل سميح لكم يعني
بالتواصل مع خصوصا ان ال ال النظام
الايراني او النظام الحبس الايراني يسمح
بالتواصل مع الوالد الموجود الداخل
هذا كثير من الاسئله سابدا من البدايه
هو راشد سياسي
في لوس انجلوس و عامله
المانيا شخصيا
ده تريكس انا
تهديدات بالقتل
واتهموه بالتجسس وانه مجرم
وفي 2009 حاولوا اغتياله هنا في
كاليفورنيا 2010
[موسيقى]
موجود داخل سجون النظام الايراني كيف هي
ظروف داخل السجن ماذا تعرفون عنه اليوم في
الداخل
وضعه سيء جدا لا يوجد معلومات كافيه عنه
فتمكننا في البدايه التواصل معه لكن في
السنه الاخيره كانت يسمح له تحدث مع
والدتي
وبند بدايه الحياه
اكيد ان شاء الله
بالحبس الانفراد الانفرادي ل 120 يوم حتى
الان
ولا نعرف ماذا حدث حتى في المرحله الراهنه
وقد خسر وهو
اتهموه
او تخريب في الارض وبالتالي اليوم همم في
المحاكمه كانت قصيره لم يتحدث عن تفاصيل
الامور ولكنهم
المحاكمه قبل ان انتقل الى موضوع جنسيته
الالمانيه بالمحاكمه هل سمح لكم بوضع
محامله ام ان النظام من وضع المحامي
وبالتالي نحن امام محاكمه صوريه
ده ده اسمه شويه
محكمه من غرفه واحده ليست محكمه حقيقيه لا
يوجد محامين المحامين الحقيقيين وراء
قضبان السجون الشخص الذي يجلس
معه وعميل للنظام
ولا اي شيء ولا تواصل مع الاسره ولا يوجد
نظام
الوالد يحمل الجنسيه الالمانيه بالاضافه
الى جنسيته الايرانيه هل تتدخلت السلطات
الالمانيه لدى السلطات الايرانيه للضغط
عليهم للافراج عنه ام انه لم يحصل اي شيء
من هذا القبيل
عبد السلام
القنصليه
الالمانيه لا يستطيعون التواصل معه ولا
يرونه حتى انهم مواطن الماني لكنه لا يسمح
له
وسلطات الايرانيه لا تسمح لهم
وحسب ما اعلم فانه خلال السنتين ونصف لم
يضغط بشكل كافر لتغيير وضعه فقط
يحكم عليه بالاعدام دون ان يفعله شيئا همم
غزاله هل لديك اي رساله ممكن ان توجهها
اليوم للسلطات الالمانيه ام للمجتمع
الدولي بخصوص وضع الوالد وبخصوص التدخل
والضغط على النظام الايراني
قاعده
هو الذي لديه الصلاحيه
الايراني
[موسيقى]
دول اخرى كاولات متحده وغيرها وان
ترعب وتغتال علينا جميعا ان نقف معا ولابد
ان يتم تمثيل تسميه المعتقلين السياسيين
كلما تحدثنا عنهم كلما
كانت ارواحهم يمكن انقاذها
لا يمكن ان ينقذ الجميع لكن على الاقل
يمكن ان نجعل من الصعوبه من مكان على
النظام
الدولي والسلطات الالمانيه وغيرها
اكل
انه من الواضح ان النظام
لكن هذا
شركاء معهم هناك كثيره
شكرا لك يا غزاله شر ما قد كنت معنا عبر
سكايب من الولايات المتحده الناشطه
الايرانيه المتحدثه باسم حمله انقذوا
شارما
وردن على التظليل الذي يقوم به اعلام
النظام الايراني تقدم شقيق رئيس التلفزيون
الايراني لللجوء بعد هروبه من كذب النظام
في حسب وصفه
جبلي شقيق بمن جبل رئيس منظمه اذاعه
وتلفزيون ايران اعلن في مقابله مع مجله
تايم الامريكيه انه اتخذ قرار اللجوء بعد
اسقاط الطائره الاوكرانيه ووفاه ابن اخيه
في هذا الحادث المجال الامريكيه اشارت الى
العلاقه بين الاذاعه والتلفزيون والحرس
الثوري الايرانيه وكتبت ان بث الاعترافات
القصريه هو احد امثله التعاون بين هاتين
المنظمتين واكد تايم ان وفاه محمد امين لم
تهز ولاء بمن المقرب من مجربه
[موسيقى]
وقع على الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف النت
واتفاق شراكه امنيه وقال امين عام حلف
شمال الاطلسيوم ان الحلف واوروبا يجب ان
يستمر في تقويه شركتهما لمواجهه بوتين على
حديث
والاتحاد
روسيا لاوكرانيا
التقينا هنا في مقر النيدو الرئيس
معا وبشكل واضح القوه الروسيه تم دحرها من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
النظام في موسكو يريد اوروبا مختلفه يريد
السيطره على جيرانه وهو يرى الحريه
والديمقراطيه كتهديد الله وسيكون لهذا اثر
على امننا على المدى البعيد ولهذا يجب ان
يستمر في تقويه الروابط بين اعضاء ويجب ان
يستمر في تقويه الشراكه بين النيته
والاتحاد الاوروبي
مزيد دعمنا لاوكرانيا
سيطره روسيا على بلده سوليدار واستعدادها
للهجوم على باخمود فيما قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان القصف الروسي العنيف لم
يحقق اي نجاح واوضحت الهيئه ان القوات
الروسيه تواصل عملياتها الهجوميه باتجاه
باخموت ولمان في محاوله لتحسين الموقع
التكتيكي باتجاه كوبيان واضافت ان الروس
اعاده تجميع صفوفهم واستقدموا قوات هجوميه
فيما اعلن الرئيس الاوكرانيا عن صمود
قواته امامها جمال جديده اكثر شده على
سوليدات اقرت المخابرات البريطانيه بان
روسيا اصبحت تسيطر على اغلب المدينه علما
بان سوليدار تقعوا في منطقه دنياس على
مسافه حوالي 15 كلم في باخماط القوات
الاوكرانيه طبعا قالت انها موسكو شنت خلال
ساعات ال 24 الماضيه احدى وثلاثين ضربه
جويه واثنين وسبعينه هجوما من منظومات
الصواريخ
ينضم الينا عبر سكايب من دونياس رائد
الاغبر مراسل العربيه ومن كاب حذيفه عادل
مراسل العربيه سابدا معك رائد بما ان
القوات الروسيه اعلنت السيطره على هذه
المدينه الاستراتيجيه بالساعات الماضيه
اهميتها ما بعد هذه المدينه بالايام
المقبله
الخاصه الروسيه
الشعبيه التي وصلت الى قلب بلده واظهرت
فيديوهات للمقاتلين امام المباني الاداريه
في قلب المدينه ما زال تقاتل في وسط
المدينه وتدفع القوات
الاوكرانيه او كما يصفون تتحرى للانسحاب
من المناطق الغربيه في ظل القسط الصاروقي
المستمر الذي لا يتوقف على طرق الامدادات
العسكريه حيث لا يسمح همم يعني الجيش
الروسي القوات الاوكرانيه بامداد
المحاصرين في المدينه بقوه اضافيه وحتى
بالعتاد هذا من جانب لكن الجانب الاخر
قطع الاتصالات عنهم فقد قطعت تماما
الاتصالات التي كانت تستخدم عبر سبوت
نكستار لينك فقد قصفت ايضا الاله العسكريه
الثقيله الروسيه اييي نقطه الاتصال نقطه
اتصال القياده في باخمه اظن مع المقاتلين
على الجبهات هذه احدى الجوانب لكن الاهم
من ذلك كله ان المعارك لا تقتصر على
سوليدار في الضغط حول الهجمات
الروسيه وتحاول الوصول الى بلده اخرى تدعى
ايبان ضمن اجل اكمال الطوق من الناحيه
الشرقيه الجنوبيه لان الجيش الروسي يعني
قاب قوسين او ادنى من اكمال الطلق من
الناحيه الشماليه والشماليه الشرقيه
والجنوبيه ويريدون ان يتقدمون من الناحيه
الشرقيه الجنوبيه في العمق نوعا ما نحو
باخبط من اجل الضغط على المقاتلين في باقه
ودفعهم للا من المدينه
لكن ال يعني المعارك الاعنف وقتال الشوارع
ما زال قائما في سندار حتى الان
سانتقل الان من عندك رائد الى الزميل
حذيفه عادل حذيفه يعني اليوم سجل حدث مهم
يعتبر زياره مسؤوله اوروبيه الى خط
المعارك وتحديدا في حركات همم يعني دلالات
هذه الزياره الدعم الغربي الذي يتنامى مع
تغيير الذي يحصل على الارض معك
مباشره بعد هذه الزياره لان لينا بوربوك
وهي وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه صرح ديمتري
كوليبا وقال انه لا يستبعد ان تصل
الدبابات الالمانيه وهو الامر الوحيد الذي
يعني كانت في اكثر من مره نفذ المانيا
انها سوف تزود الجيش الاوكراني بهذه
الدبابات قال انني لا استبعد ان تكون هذه
الدبابات قريبا في ارض المعركه هي بشكل
واضح صرحت انهم يقفون خلف الشعب الاوكراني
ارسلت رساله للشعب الاوكراني من الخارجف
وقالت ان الدعم مستمر الدعم الالماني
مستمر والدعم من جميع الدول الصديقه مستمر
طبعا ايضا اليوم كان هناك همم يعني
مباحثات اجراها الرئيس
عدد من رؤساء همم
رؤساء وزراء عدد من الدول وبالاضافه الى
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون واتحدث ايضا
عن الامدادات العسكريه وخاصه الدبابات
الفرنسيه اي ام اكس 10 وهي دبابات همم
يعني فعاليه كبيره في ارض المعركه وتؤدي
هجوميه بيئه امتياز ايضا طبعا تم اعلنت
عدد من وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه من بينها
سي انعن ان في الاسبوع القادم ستبدا همم
عدد من القوات الاوكرانيه في التدريبات في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على نظام
باتريوت همم نظام باتنه طبعا الان هو من
الانظمه المهمه جدا في القتال كذلك يعني
تحدث القياده العسكريه يعني عاده همم
الدعومات العسكريه التي ستصل في الايام
القليله القادمه الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
اما بخصوص الادادار قبل 40 دقيقه فقط
وهو المتحدث باسم القوات المقاتله في
الشرق قال نفى تماما ان تكون القوات
الروسيه قد سيطرت على مدينه سوليدار وقال
ان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت في مواقععها
وتحدث ايضا عن وضع الامدادات وقال اصبح
وضع الامداد معقدا ولكن ليس مقطوعه تماما
وهنالك امكانيه ايصال الزخائر الى القوات
المقاتله في السليدار وقال ان العقيد همم
اليكساندر سيرسكي وهو عق- من ال- من
الجنرالات المعروفين طبعا المشهورين في
الجيش الاوكراني قالوا انه يقود القوات في
تلك المنطقه وما زالت القوات في مواقعها
ولم تتقدم وان وقال ايضا ان الروس يعني
يتكبدون خسائر كبيره وهم يحاولون التقدم
على حساب اعداد او خسائر جنودهم وقال ان
القتلى باعداد كبيره جدا هذا فيما يخص
الاداره وطبعا هنالك ايضا اليوم كان هنالك
قصف
اليكساندر شهد قصف كبير من قبل القوات
الاتحاد الروسي فقالت وزاره الدفاع الكليه
انها نفذت اليوم 10 ضربه جويه واربعه
ضربات لي مراكز همم يعني مستودعات لي
الاسلحه والذخائر وانظمه الدفاع الجوي
ساخصم معك رائد الاستراتيجيه باخموت يعني
بالساعات الماضيه كنا نسمع عنها ما هي هذه
الاستراتيجيه باختصار لو سمحت بالمعركه
القادمه
همم
لابد من التذكير بان الاستراتيجيه للقوات
الروسيه بشكل عام منذ بدايه العمليات
العسكريه كانت هي قدم الاراضي بلده البلده
وحيدا والاخر اليوم تعود القوات الروسيه
ان كانت الخاصه او الجيش الروسي الفدرالي
بشكل عام بالتقدم مثلا من النواحي
الشماليه في دنه حيث سيطرت على عده بلدات
منها قرودنا وكراس نيجارات ومن انتقلت الى
بلده اخرى وهي
الان من الناحيه الجنوبيه الشرقيه نتحدث
عن اوضه همم معارك ضاريه في بلده ومن ثم
يعني يتقدم الجيش الروسي للوصول الى
ايمانه عاده استراتيجيه الى الغطاء بسلاح
الجو المقاتل الروسيات تقصد بصواريخ
استراتيجيه بضربات دقيقه مواقع القوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه مع تقدم على الارض
للقوات البريه على شكل او استراتيجيه قد
من الاراضي ولو تقدم خفيف وبطيء لكنه تقدم
محسوب واا بالنهايه يعني يحسن المعاني
بهذه الظروف المناخيه الصعبه شكرا لكم
بعد حوالي عام من الحرب يستغرب محلله فرن
بوليسي الغياب شبه التام لاي نقاش بين
السياسيين
وصانعي القرار حول عواقب الهزيمه على
روسيا الامر الذي تعتبره المجله امرا خطرا
بالنظر الى احتمال انهيار روسيا وتفكها
الجمع بين حرب فاشله في الخارج ونظام
الهاش في الداخل يزيد من احتماليه حدوث
نوع من الانهيار الداخلي بغض النظر اذا
كان هذا جيد ام سيء للغرب فهو نتيجه يجب
على صانعي السياسه الاستعداد لها تقول
نساء هناك سيناريوهات مختلفه مشاهدينا لما
قد يحدث في روسيا بعد ما تصبح لهزيمه في
اوكرانيا اكثر وضوحا على الارجح هو رحيل
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين من منصبه
يليه صراع شرس على السلطه بين القوميين
اليمنيين الذين يريدون مواصله الحرب
وتدمير تسلسل الهرمي السياسيه الحالي وبين
حركه شبه ديمقراطيه صاعده ملتزمه بانهاء
الحرب واصلاحه روسيا الوصول الى هذه
المرحله سيدعوا الروس الساقطين الى النزول
الى الشوارع ربما حتى بالسلاح ويشجع بعض
المناطق العرقيه غير الروسيه على اختيار
المزيد من الحكم الذاتي ترشح مشاهدينا فرن
البوليسي ان تظهر هذه النزاعات في
تتارستان والشيشان و داغستان وغيرها هذه
السيناريوهات التي تعتبر حلم منزل اوكران
ودعميهم يمكن ان تكون كارثه عالميه بحسب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الاسباب هذه
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
وثائق سريه في مكتبي وترامب يتهكم متى متى
ستداهمون منازله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنتا البحريه
الامريكيه اعتراض سفينه صيد في خليج عمان
كانت في طريقها من ايران الى اليمن وقالت
قياده المركزيه الامريكيه في بيان لها ان
السفينه كان علمتنها اكثر من 2100 بندقيه
هجوميه وتم ااا ضبطها في السادس من يناير
الماضي وقال قائد القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه ان القوه البحريه ستظل ينقض في
الكشف عن اي نشاط بحري يعوقوا حريه
الملاحه او يعرض الامن الاقليمي للخطر
وشيرا الى ان شحنه الاسلحه جزء من نمط
مستمر لنشاط ايران المزعزع للاستقرار
نظم ابناء قبائل يمنيه وقفه احتجاجيه
للتمديد بقرارات الاعدام التي اعلنت عنها
ميليشيات الحوثي بحق ابنائهم وحذر
المحتاجون من ابناء القبائل ميليشيات
الحوثي من انتفاضه شعبيه غاضبه ضد قرارات
الاعدام كما دعا المحتجون المجتمع الدولي
الى تحمل المسؤوليه والضغط على الميليشيات
لوقف قرارات الاعدام بحق ابنائهم
لا نعلم اي شيء بخير صاحي 100
بعد ثمان سنين افطرت الحوثي علي بالاعدام
من دون اي سبب
نطالب بالافراج عنه تم استلام القارات
بحقهم تحت مسمى ااا محاكمه
هجليه
بمحكمه هذه المحكمه ليس لها ولايه في
المحاكمه في حقهم وانما هي قرارات سياسيه
ان تكاميه بهدف همم بهدف اسكات الاصوات
الحره انه ارهابي اليمنيين بقرارات
الاعدام والاعتقال والتعذيب والتهذيب
والتجويد لن يجري ما لهم الامان وسيعجل
بغضبه شعبيه
[موسيقى]
مجددا اوراق طبعت بالسريه يعثر عليها في
غير مكانها لكن هذه المره في ادراج الرئيس
الامريكي
سريه من حقبه اوباما اي حين كان بيضا
نائبا للرئيس عثر عليها في نوفمبر الماضي
اثناء اغلاق مكتب خاص به فالمواد الحكوميه
وجدت في خزانه مغلقه بمركز ايضا
للديبلوماسيه والمشاركه العالميه ومقره
العاصمه واشنطن وبحسب شبكه سي ان المواد
تضمنت ملفات سريه للغايه مع وصم المعلومات
الحساسه المشعه مصطلحوا يستخدم للمعلومات
البالغه الحساسيه التي تم الحصول عليها من
مصادر استخباراتيا اكتشاف هذه الوثائق
مشاهدينا تم من قبل محامي الرئيس ولم تكن
الوثائق موضوع اي طلب او استفسار سابق من
قبل المحفوظات هؤلاء اتصلوا على اثرها
باداره المحفوظات والسجلات وطنيه التي
ارسلت بدورها الى وزاره العدل للنظر في
الامر
[موسيقى]
الى خزانه مقفله وجدوا وثائق يبدو انها
تحوي علامات سريه وفقا للبيت الابيض ابلغ
محامو الرئيس مكتب مستشار البيت الابيض
على الفاور الذي اتصل بعد ذلك باداره
المحفوظات والسجلات الوطنيه وبدورها تولت
عهده تلك الوثائق في صباح اليوم التالي ثم
ابلغت ايضا وزاره العدل لاجراء مراجعه
لذلك ولطريقه التي تم بها التعامل مع
المستندات
المدعي العام كلف المدعي العام في شيكاغو
بمراجعه الوثائق مع مشاركه مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي بعمليه التقصف وياتي اكتشاف
المواد في وقت تواصل فيه التحقيقات مع
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب لاحتمال اساءه
التعامل مع نحو 325 وثيقه سريه تراب
بالطبع استغل هذه الانباء واتساءل متهما
متى ستتم مداهمه مكتب تحقيقات الفيدرالي
لمنازل جو بايدن او حتى للبيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
فاصوليا
وهذه مشاهدينا صور خاصه بالعربيه لمكتب
بايدن الذي وجدت الوفاق في داخله اذا هذه
الصور الخاصه بقناه العربيه للمكتب الذي
وجدت به الوثائق التي وصفت وطبعت بالسريه
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه الوثائق التي عثر عليها بمكتب
السابق لرئيس بايجن ااه تاتي قبيله وقت
قصير من اعلان وزاره العدل الامريكيه
تعيين محامي مستقل للنظر بتوجيه اتهام
جنائي لترامب بشان الملفات التي عثر عليها
ايضا في منزله فانتقل الان الى واشنطن
والزمالك
العربيه ناديه نحن اليوم يعني امام
اشكاليتين اشكاليه قانونيه واشكاليه
سياسيه بهذا الملف كيف هي التفاصيل ما هي
التفاصيل وكيف هي الاجواء مباشره
اهلا بك ليال انا اقف الان امام هذا
المبنى طبعا في الطابق السادس يوجد المكتب
الذي تم العثور على هذه الوثائق السريه
منه قبل قليل طبعا حصلنا على هذه الصور
الحصريه من خلال شخص يعمل في داخل المبنى
اييه قانونيا البيت الابيض على الاقل ليس
علنا لكن حسب بعض التسريبات يقول بانه لا
يوجد هناك اشكال قانوني همم لعديد من
الاسباب الاولى بانه بمجرد ان وجدها محامي
الرئيس
الوطني لم تكن مطلوبه ولم تكن اذا اردت
ضائعه وبالتالي كان هناك تعاون كبير جدا
بين محمير رئيس وما بين
الارشيف الوطني الوطني
لكن سياسيا هذا سيكون مدمر لي الرئيس
سيتهم بازدواجيه المعايير اولا حتى لو لم
تكون هناك مقارنه بينه وبين رئيس ترامب
الذي كان هناك في حوزته 3 وثيقه سريه
وكانت مطلوبه واختفت وكان هناك مداه في
بيتي الامر مختلف نعم لا يوجد هناك مقارنه
لكن عن كل الاحوال همم واشنطن مشحونه
حسبيا وسياسيا قبل قليل لجنه الاستخبارات
بالفونجرس بتشكيلاتها الجديده التي يسيطر
عليها الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب طلب
مراجعه مدى الخطر من خلال هذه الوثائق
لطلب رسمي طبعا لابريل هاينز وهي رئيسه
الاستخبارات العامه
على النقطه الاولى وهي الناحيه القانونيه
بما انه يعني كل المحيطين بالرئيس ترامب
السابق تحدث عن هذه النقطه اليوم لوسائل
الاعلام لان قانون السجلات الرئاسيه ينص
على ضروره تسليم جميع الوثائق من اداره
الرئيس وموظفيه الى الارشيف الوطني فورا
انتهاء المهام الرسميه هل هذا يتعارض مع
ما اعلنه البيت الابيض ام لا
او ما صرب من هناك
هذا صحيح
صحيح لا يتعارض اكيد لانه من ناحيه
قانونيه كما ذكرت كل شخص وكان على مستوى
الرئيس نائب الرئيس او اي مسؤول مستشار
الامن القومي هذه الوثائق التي تصنف بانها
السريه على فكره يعني حتى احيانا تكون
عاديه لكنها تسمى كلاسيفيد
ضمن تصنيف الحكومه الامريكيه لكن بغض
النظر اذا كانت بالفعل تحمل اسرار كما
قالت يلين قبل قليل بان هذه الوثائق تضم
معلومات حول ايران حول اوكرانيا حول
بريطانيا عندما كان اا بعض النائب للرئيس
ربما الاطلاعيه على بعض المعلومات
المتعلقه بالسياسه الخارجيه لكن على
الرئيس ونائب الرئيس ان يسلموها بمجرد الى
البيت الابيض الى السجل الوطني
كما يسمى لكن على كل الاحوال اكيد سيكون
هناك محاسبه وسيكون هناك تدقيق وسيكون
هناك موقف محرج للبيت الابيض الرئيس في
المكسيك يحضر هذه القمه مع كندا باستضافه
المكسيك طبعا يتحدث عن موضوع المهاجرين
تغيير المناخي وغير حول الصحفيين
المنافقين له اا السؤال مرتين عن هذه
الوثائق السريه لم يجب لكنه لن يستطيع
التهرب لفتره طويله اكيد البيت الابيض
الان في حلب قلق واضطراب كيف سيرد على
اسئله الصحفيين لانه بغض النظر كما قلت لم
يكن هناك مقارنه سيكون هناك محاسبه سياسيه
خصوصا من الجمهوريين الذين يترصدون لرئيس
ينتظرون هذه اللحظات وبالتالي سيكون موقف
سياسي محرج للبيت الابيض عليه ان يبرره ان
يدافع عنه وان يعلمنا كيف لم يتم تسليم
هذه الوسائل الوثائق
للسجل الوطني شكرا لك ناديه البلبيسي
مراسله العربيه حدثنا واشنطن
[موسيقى]
الهدوء الحظر عادا لارجاء العاصمه
البرازيليه والامن بسطه سيطرته على قصر
الرئاسه ومنشات حيويه اخرى غير ان وضع
احداث الشغب والاحتجاجات بخانه الارهاب
جعلت الاف المعتقلين يواجهون تهاما
عقوبتها وخيمه الشرطه البرازيليه اعتقلت
الفن 1500 شخص من انصار الرئيس السابق
جلال بورسنارو وهؤلاء اقطعهم مباني
الحكوميه في العاصمه وتغم بالحاق اضرار
كبيره بالمقائد الثلاثه الكونجرس مكتب
الرئيس والمحكمه العليا وفي وقت اذان
الرئيس من وصفهم بمسيريب بسبب اعمال
الارهابيه وفاشيه وفق تعبيره فكك مئات
الجنود ايضا والشرطه خارج مقر الجيش
الرئيسي في برازيليا وهناك كان انصار
سونارو ينظمون احتجاجا منذ اسابيع وهناك
ايضا جرت معظم الاعتقالات الرئيس
البرازيلي الذي ربح الانتخابات بفارق بسيط
في اكتوبر قشطه مع بقاده مجلسي الكونجرس
ورئيس المحكمه العليا بيان المنبثق عن
الاجتماع الثلاثي رفض احداث البرازيليه
التي تدخل في اطار التخريب الاجرامي
والترويج للانقلاب اما في العاصمه فاكد
وزير العدل الاحتجاز الشرطه لنحو 40 حافله
كانت تستخدم لنقل المتظاهرين مضيفا ان
التحقيقات ستركز على من قام بتنظيم
الاحتجاجات وتمويلها
[موسيقى]
دعت رئيسه تايوان المانيا للمساعده في
الحفاظ على النظام الاقليمي في اجتماع مع
مشرعين المانيا
[موسيقى]
ديمقراطيه والحريه اعتبارا من العام
المقبل سيتم تمديد الخدمه العسكريه
الالزاميه تايوان الى عامل واحد لتعزيز
قدرتنا الدفاعيه واظهار عزمنا على الدفاع
عن وطننا وحمايه الديمقراطيه نحن نتطلع
الى تايوان والمانيا والشركاء
الديمقراطيين الاخرين معا الحفاظ على
النظام الاقليمي والازدهار
من جهتها صرحت رئيسه لجنه الدفاع
البرلمانيه الالمانيه ان بلادها وتايوان
تقفان معا كدولتين ديمقراطين خاصه بعد
الهجوم التي جنته روسيا على اوكرانيا
لم يكن هذا الهجوم الاول من روسيا على
اوكرانيا لكن هذا الهجوم كان بمثابه جرس
انذار كبيره ليس فقط لاوروبا ولالمانيا
ولكن ايضا للعالم باسره والان يمكننا ان
نرى ما حدث في اوكرانيا وهي يؤثر على
العالم باسره مجيئنا الى هنا لنقول للعالم
اننا نقف قريبين من بعضنا البعض كدول
الديمقراطيه
معركه دون رابح مع خسارات وازنه على
الجبهتين هذا ما اظهرته سيناريوهات متعدده
تحاكي غزوه صينيه لتايوان الجزيره التي
تتمتع بحكم الذكي وتطالب الصين بالسعادتها
بالقوه اللازمه الامر بالتالي 24 سيناريو
اجراهم مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والدوليه في واشنطن استبعد جميع هذه
السيناريوهات خروج الصين منتصره منها كذا
حرب بل دفع الصين اثمانا هائله وبحسب
المحاكاه الحرب ستترك البحريه الصينيه في
حاله من الفوضى وتحطم جوهر قوتها البحريه
والبريه وستفقد الصين
155 طائره مقاتله
و138 سفينه كبيره وفقا تقرير خسارتها تمتد
لقواتها مع توقعات بمقتل حوالي 10,000 من
جنودها وا عشرات الالاف في خانه المدافعين
عن تايوان تقف الولايات المتحده مع
اليابان البلدان سيخسران عشرات السفن
البحريه ومئات الطائرات المقاتله وخصائر
بشريه بالالاف بحسب التقرير فمعظم
السيناريوهات تتوقع ان تفقد البحريه
الامريكيه حاملتي طائرات وما بين 10 الى
20 سفينه مقاتله كبيره فيما تقول التوقعات
ان نحو ثلاثه الاف ومئتين جندي امريكي
سيلقون مصرعهم خلال ثلاثه اسابيع من
القتال اين نحو نصف ما خسيرته في عقدين من
القتال في كل من العراق وافغانستان
اليابان ايضا خسائرها ليست بالقليله وفقا
المحاكاه اكثر من 100 طائره مقاتله و 26
سفينه حربيه بينما تتعرض القواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه على اراضيها لهجوم اذا حاله شلل
ستعديها
انا الثلاثه في حال حدوث الغزو الواسع
النطاق للجزيره البالغ عدد سكانها 24
مليون نسمه لكنه مستبعد وفق خبراء طبعا
فرغنا قيامها بعمليات توهل منتظمه في
المياه والمجال الجوي قربه ايوان الا ان
بكين لم تخاطر بهكذا مناوره معدومه
النتائج وتضر اقتصادها بشكل هائل
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا الان الصور الاولى لوزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه التي زارت مدينه خاركه
في اوكرانيا حيث التقت نظيرها الاوكراني
دي متروكوليبا لتكون الوزيره الالمانيه
اول مسؤوله غربيه تزور الجبهه في اوكرانيا
وقالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه اثناء
تواجدها ان هذه المدينه رمز للجنون المطلق
لحرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا سنعود مع الصور همم تتابعونا
في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
الملك سلمان يواجه باستمرار الدعم الاضافي
المقدم لمستفيدي حساب المواطن حتى مارس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا عشيه حسن
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه في الالتماس
المقدم لشطب تعيين زعيم حزب شاس وزيرا في
الحكومه الجديده بسبب الازالاته المتكرره
في قضايا فساد سر على الائتلاف الحكومي
خطته لفرد قيود على النظام القضائي في
اسرائيل بتغليب قرارات الكنيست على قرارات
المحاكم
لا تهدر الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده وقتا
في ضعف النظام القضائي في اسرائيل حيث
فجرت جدلا في الساحتين السياسيه والقضائيه
باطلاق خطتها التي تنص على تشريع قانون
يغلب قرارات الكنيست اي السياسيين على
قرارات القضاء وتامين اغلبيه بواقع سبعه
من اصل 11 عضوا في لجنه تعيين القضاء
لصالح الائتلاف والغاء ما يسمى بفقره
المعقوليه في الاحكام القضائيه التي تحمل
الافراد والمجموعات من تنفيذ او عدم تنفيذ
الحكومه قرارات تؤثر في حياتهم انت مين
تطبيق السياسه التي وعدنا بها الجمهور
وانتخبنا من اجلها واعتقد بان مواطني
اسرائيل يشعرون بذلك جيدا لقد فكرنا حكومه
مختلفه ولها سياسه وغيره وتتصرف على نحو
مختلف في المعارضه اعتبرو ان الحكومه بدات
انقلاب على النظام القضائي والسياسي
لمساعده نتنياهو في محاكمته الجاريه
بقضايا فساد وخلق ديكتاتوريه الاغلبيه
التي تهضم حقوق الاقليات والافراد وبدات
في النزول الى الشارع للتظاهر اسبوعيا
والمحكمه ستتالف من مقربين للسلطه
السياسيون سيعيون قضاه خانعين ينفدون ما
يطلب منهم سيكون انقلابا خطيرا على نظام
الحكم جل النقاش يطال الاغلبيه اليهوديه
الفلسطينيه داخل اسرائيل في ظل وجود تمييز
تعترف به الحكومات المتعاقبه
اثنين تعتبر عنصريه مثل قانون القوميه
الذي يعرف اسرائيل بانها دوله لليهود لا
لجميع مواطنها وهو سقف اداء الجهاز
القضائي الاسرائيلي ايضا بحقهم
الحكومه المتطرفه في اسرائيل تحاول
اخضاعها النظام القضائي والغاء الحدود بين
السلطتين القضائيه والتنفيذيه لصالح
الاخيره فيما تستغل المعارضه معارضه معظم
الشارع الاسرائيلي وفق استطلاعات الراي
للحرب على القضاء لجر المواجهه الى الشارع
زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اظهرت صور للاقمار
الصناعيه ومقاطع فيديو ومنشوره على وسائل
التواصل ادله مرئيه واضحه بان السجلات
الصينيه الرسميه لا تعكس الخسائر الكامله
لتفشي فيروس كورونا لاسيما الوفيات واشنطن
بوست واضافت الصحيفه ان الصور تقود الدعاء
بكين بان تفشي المرض لا يزال تحت السيطره
حيث تظهر نشاطا غير اعتياديا في دور
الجنائز او في دور الجنائز وحشودا في
محارق الجثث بالعاصمه بكين ومناطق عده
مقارنه بالاشهر القليله الماضيه في الوقت
نفسه من العام الماضي كما توضح ازاحه مساء
مساحات جديده لمواقف السيارات لم تكن
موجوده سابقا علما بان دور الجنازه توقفت
عن تقديم خدمات العزاء وخاصه دقيقتين فقط
لكل اسره لتوضيع احبائها قبل حرق الجثه
متحول جديد من فيروس كورونا يجدد المخاوف
التي لم تهدا بعد لدى الجهات الصحيه
والعالم باسره فمنظمه الصحه العالميه كشفت
عن متحور ينتمي لسلاله اوميكرو لكنه يمتلك
ميزه النمو بشكل اكبر المتحول المعروف
باكس بي بي وان فايف يعاد اكثر المتغيرات
قدره على الانتشار بين كل السلالات التي
اكتشفت حتى اللحظه اكس بيبي وان 5 اعراضه
مشابهه لاعراض سلالات او ميكروسابقه وان
كان من المبكر تاكيد ذلك وفق منظمه الصحه
لكن هل المتحول الجديد اكثر عدوى او خطوره
من المتحورات السابقه تطور مشاهدينا اكس
بي وان فايف من سلالات اكس بي بي ولكن
اخذت بالانتشار في بريطانيا خلال سبتمبر
الماضي لكنها لم تصنف كم متحور مثير للقلق
من قبل السلطات المحليه الصحيه المتحول
الجديد [__] سبع طفرارات
ما يزيد صعوبه معجزه المناعيه في التعرف
على المتغير الفرعي والزياد احتماليه
تفادي الاجسام المضاده احدى الطفرات تجعله
ينتشر بسهوله فيما يعتقد ان طفره اخرى
تحسن من قدره المتحور على الارتباط
بالخلايا غير ان علماء طمان الى عدم وجود
ادله تثبت ان المتحول الجديد اكثر خطوره
او ضررا من متغيرات او ميكروس السابقه
ينضم الينا عبر سكايب من اكسفورد الدكتور
احمد سلمان استاذ علم المناعه وتطوير
اللقاحات في جامعه اكسفورد استاذ يعني نحن
اليوم امام نسخه اسوا بكثير من المتحورات
التي شاهدناها بظل سرعه يعني الانتشار هل
نحن امام يعني ازمه عالميه جديده ام انه
ممكن السيطره عليها
مساء الخير تحياتي لحضرتك والساده
المشاهدين
للاسف طبعا هو متوقع خلال هذه الفتره من
الشتاء ان يحدث يعني ظهور وارتفاع
لاعراض الاصابات واعداد الاصابات في
الفيروسات التنفسيه عموما ومنها طبعا
السلالات الموجوده الان الاكثر يعني
انتشارا سواء في الشرق في الصين بي اف 7
وفي الغرب
والشرق الاوسط اكس بي بي 1 5 اللي هم
منبثقين كانوا متحولات من اومكرون فاير
همم للاسف يعني التاثير بيكون اوضح على
المناعه المجتمعيه يعني مثلا في الصين
تقريبا معدل الانتشار حتى في اكس بي بي 1
5 اعلى من همم نظيره في همم الصين او اللي
هو 7 ولكن للاسف المناعه المجتمعيه
المنخفضه جدا في الجانب الصيني لذلك يعني
للاسف كان التاثير الان امم العامل المهم
الذي يتم اخذه في الاعتبار بهذه الفتره
بعد وجود اللقاحات بعد وجود المناعه
المجتمعيه ليست اعداد الاصابه اعداد
الاصابات يعتبر يعني طبعا منها نسبه قديمه
مهمه ولكن المهم عندنا الان هي الحالات
الحرجه او لا قدر الله الوفيات هنا عامل
المهم او الحاسمه
ولماذا يعني ما معنى انه اندماج لعده
متحولات داخل الجسد
مهمه جدا هذه النقطه يعني الادويه اغلبها
فعال بالفعل ولكن لازم او يعني لابد من
استخدام هذه الادويه في مراحل متقدمه قبل
ان يحدث مثلا تكون اعراض شديده منها مثلا
تكون الجلطات في مناطق معينه في الرئه او
في الجهاز التنفسي او حتى في اعضاء اخرى
من الاعضاء المهمه زي المخ مثلا والكبد
والكلى ودي جايز يعني من اسوا ال- الاعراض
ليه فيروس الكره المستجد هو يبدو في الوهن
الاولى انه فيروس تنفسي لانه بينتقل اسرع
ولكن اعراضه مختلفه تماما او يعني اعراضه
خطره ليست هي الاعراض الدارجه مثلا همم
لالتهابات الجهاز التنفسي وبالتالي مهم
جدا توقيت اخذ الدواء اذا تم تلقي الدواء
في مرحله متقدمه قبل ظهور الاعضاء وقبل
يعني فشل الاعضاء همم ممكن طبعا تكون نسبه
العلاج فعاله بنسبه عاليه ولكن اذا حدث
تدمير للعضو نتيجه العدوى بالفيروس حتى
اذا تم القضاء على الفيروس لا يتم احياء
العضو مره اخرى او اعاده كفاءه عمله
وبالتالي مهم جدا توقيت اخذ العلاج وسيضل
عندنا ايضا الوقايه خير من العلاج ان تتبع
اصلا الاصابه عن طريق اللقاحات او الوقايه
ايه باستخدام الطرق الحرازيه قدر المستطاع
صوره حرجه ليه خصوصا في اوروبا مع ضعف
القدره الاستيعابيه للمستشفيات وايضا في
الولايات المتحده اذا ما استمر الانتشار
السريع لهذا الفايروس
بصوره مؤكده اا لسنا في حال سيء مقارنه
بدايه الوبارك توجد مناعه مجتمعيه مهما
ظهرت عندنا متحولات جديده ستظل هناك نسبه
من الفعاليه او المناعه موجوده وستؤدي دور
كبير جدا في منع الدخول في الاعراض الحرجه
والوفيات حتى اذا حدثت يعني الاصابه وحدث
ارتفاع ملحوظ في الاصابات لكن الموضوع
لعبه ارقام يعني او نسبه وتناسب مهما كان
هناك مناعه مجتمعيه سيظل هناك نسبه قليله
من الاعداد ستتحول الى اعراض حرجه او لقدر
الله تتطلب دخول المستشفى وممكن يحدث منها
وفيات وبالتالي مهم جدا ايضا اخذ الاعتبار
مقارنه طبعا بدايه الوباء اذا كان عندك
مثلا 1,000 شخص مصابين ممكن يتوفى منهم
همم يعني مثلا 30 او 40 شخص ولكن هذا
الوفيات يكون من مليون شخص ولكن مهم جدا
ان ان لا ننسى لعبه الارقام انه لو في
عندي اصابه مثلا 100 مليون شخص سيظل هناك
عدد كبير من هذه
السلطه شكرا لك يا دكتور احمد سلمان
حدثتنا من اكثر
ورغم الانتشار الواسع للفيروس في الصين
قال المدير الاقليمي لمنطقه اوروبا في
منظمه الصحه العالميه ان المنظمه لا تتوقع
ان يؤدي هذا الانتشار الى تاثير كبير على
الوضع الوبائي في اوروبا
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه فان الزياده في
نوعين من الطفرات الفيروسيه المنتشره في
الصين هي تلك التي شهدت بالفعل في اوروبا
واماكن اخرى نشارك وجهه النظر الحاليه
للمركز الاوروبي لمكافحه الامراض بان
الارتفاع المسجل في الصين ليس من المتوقع
ان يؤثر بشكل كبير على الوضع الوبائي 2019
في المنطقه الاوروبيه في هذا الوقت
اعلنت الخارجيه الصينيه ان السفارتها في
كوريا الجنوبيه ستعلق تاشيرات الزياره
القصيره المده للكوريين ردا على قيود
طبقتها سول على الوافدين من الصين ووصفتها
بكين بالتمييزيه
[موسيقى]
وجهها العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وبناء على ما رفعه ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان باستمرار الدعم
الاضافي المقدم لمستفيدي برنامج حساب
المواطن لمده ثلاثه اشهر اضافيه وحتى دفعه
شهر مارس 2023 الى جانب باستمرار فتح
تسجيل في البرنامج وياتي ذلك استمرار
للتوجيه الصادر في شهر يوليو من عام 2020
والذي تضمن تخصيص مبلغ 20 مليار ريال وكان
صدر امر ملكي في يوليو من العام الماضي
بتخصيص مبلغ ثمانيه مليارات ريال كدعم من
اضافه للمستفيدين من برنامج حساب المواطن
لنهايه العام 2010
كشف محافظ هيئه الحكومه الرقميه احمد
السويدان ان من اولويات هيئه الحكومه
الرقميه دمج منصات وتحول من 36 منصه في
قطاع الحج الى منصه نفق مشيرا الى ان منصه
نصف تقدم 121 خدمه تتنوع بين قطاع الاعمال
والافراد لخدمه 30 مليون شخص
بعد عامين من القيود التي فرضتها كورونا
تعود اعداد الحجاج الى وضعها الطبيعي دون
قيود او شروط وبنفس الاعداد لمواسم ما قبل
الجائحه فوفقا لاخر الاحصائيات الرسميه
لجايحات كورونا فقد وصل عدد الحجاج لعام
2019 الى نحو مليونين ونصف المليون حقش
لكن ماذا عن الاشتراطات المرتبطه بالتحصين
للحجاج القادمين من خارج السعوديه وزاره
الحج والعمره بينت للعربيه انه يشتر
التلقي الحجاج ثلاثه تحصينات ضد كرونه ضد
الحمى الشوكيه اضافه الى لقاح الانفلونزا
الموسميه وهو ما ينطبق على حجاج الداخل
كما اعلن سابقا وتشهد مدينه جده استمرار
اعمال اليوم الثاني من معرض ومؤتمر اكسبو
الحاج بمشاركه واحد و80 متحدثا من
القطاعين العام والخاص ووفدا من سبع نسينا
دوله حول العالم للعمل على تحسين تجربه
الحجاج ونعود لنذكر مشاهدينا بما اكده
وزير الحج والعمره الدكتور توفيق الربيعه
ان حج هذا العام لن يشترط فيه حد اعلى
لاعمار الحجاج والذي كان مقررا في العام
الماضي عند 65 عاما كما كشف الربيعه خلال
كلمته في معرض اكسبو الحاج عن تخفيض تكلفه
التامين على حجاج هذا العام بالنسبه ثلاثه
لتصبح عند سبعه وثمانون ريالا فقط
يسرني اليوم
بشارتين
في هذا اللقاء
البشره الاولى
عوده اعداد الحجاج الى ما كانت عليه قبل
الجائحه وبدون اي قيود على العمر
بعثه من اي دوله في العالم عاده ترتبط
بمؤسسه خدمات واحده
في خدمات الحج
ولتعزيز التنافسيه
وتطوير الخدمات وتعزيز الان وابتداء من
هذا العام اي بعثه الحج اي مكتب حج من اي
مكان في العالم يستطيع التعاقد مع اي شركه
مرخصه تحقق المتطلبات اللي يحتاجها حجاج
هذه الدوله
وجهها ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بدراسه زياده الاستثمارات السعوديه
في باكستان والمعلن في الخامس والعشرين من
اغسطس الماضي لتصل الى 10 مليارات دولار
وفقا لوكاله الانباء السعوديه كما يدرس
صندوق السعودي للتنميه زياده مبلغ الوديعه
المقدمه لصالح البنك المركزي الباكستانيه
المعلن عنها في الثاني من ديسمبر الماضي
لتصل الى خمسه مليارات دولار
[موسيقى]
اذا بالعوده الى الملف الاوكراني هذه
الصور الاولى مشاهدينا لزيارات وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه الى خارجاف كما
وعدناكم قبل قليل اذا هذه الزياره
الدبلوماسيه الارفع منذ بدا الحرب الى خط
او جبهه المعركه
الختام مع العناوين
اعدامات جديده في ايران ونقابه المعلمين
تطالب بوقفها وباقامه محاكمات عاجله بحضور
محامين
شراكه امنيه بين الناتو واوروبا والحلف
يؤكد ثقته بانضمام السويد
تحتوي الاف البنادق الهجوميه البحريه
الامريكيه تضبط سفينه ايرانيه تهرب سلاحا
للحوثيين
زياده وحالات كورونا في الصين لا يقلق
اوروبا وبكين تفرض اجراءات عقابيه على سول
وتوكيو
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت